man it is going to be hot outside here
sherry it is and i hope you got a lot
from that interview with paul about
eating right eating hydrating foods not
overdoing it
eating heavy meals can really weigh you
down don't you notice that you
you feel slow and sluggish in this heat
it slows down your body it slows down
your mind
we're dealing with 90s just to get
started on our friday
so not only are we setting records in
the afternoon but we're setting records
in the morning for
extra warm temperatures and of course we
only have
to go up from here right yesterday 114
today
1 15. that's a new record high for
today's date july 9.
normal high is 104. sundown is 8 o'clock
so we have a long time for that hot
sunshine to cook us today
long duration heat wave it's intense and
i know that a lot of folks say hey i've
lived here a long time i get it i know
one teens we can do it
but it's day after day after day and the
heat risk
is very high for all of us if we're
outdoors for a really long period of
time remember that sun
adds another 10 to 15 degrees of heat on
your body so it's going to feel like
it's about
125 to 130 degrees in the direct sun
all thanks to this high pressure now
there is a little mid-level moisture
trapped under that high pressure and it
could produce some isolated
thunderstorms in the higher elevations
today
through the weekend and right into early
next week 90 degrees up at mount
charleston
there's not much relief up there but i
know a lot of people are going to head
up there
and try to cool off just know that it's
not going to be
that cool in the mountains either 115
though
is well above normal as i said staying
hydrated
eating hydrated foods and taking
advantage of that ac
is the best thing you can do and
limiting your time outdoors
117 it's the hottest temp we've ever
recorded at mccarran
for las vegas and we could match it we
might even beat it this weekend that's
how intense
this heat wave is we don't get a break
till later next week we get a few clouds
a little more humidity
and we'll finally drop below 110 but
still staying above normal